in nordhausen in thüringen spielt sich
früh am morgen reichlich merkwürdiges ab
werktags um 34 startet ein geisterzug
richtung göttingen in niedersachsen
fahrgäste dürfen aber nicht einsteigen
weil der freistaat thüringen für die
frühverbindung zahlen wenn dürfen
reisende us-team niedersachsen zu
steigen ohne passagiere komplett leer
fährt der zug durch den südharz
man sollte die leute einen aussteigen
lassen
vor allem frühmorgens wenn ich heute
sagen wir wirklich auf arbeit wollen
es ist unverantwortlich als einfacher
bürger sich diese ganze sache ist sie
auch bescheuert sein wenn ich wieder
losfahren muss früh muss aufarbeitung
kasten zog später fahren weil dazu
lieber leer fährt ist für mich sinnlos
seit dem fahrplanwechsel ende 2018 rollt
der geisterzug durch thüringen der grund
die bundesländer bestellen und bezahlen
den regionalverkehr bei der deutschen
bahn dem freistaat aber ist die frühe
verbindung zu teuer die insgesamt rund
66 euro stationsgebäude pro tag will man
in erfurt sparen die folge an den fünf
bahnhöfen in thüringen kann niemand zu
steigen
als hinter der landesgrenze beim ersten
halt dem niedersächsischen walkenried
dürfen die lokführer die türen öffnen
gerade für berufspendler ein schlechter
scherz auf thüringer seite sind sie
entsprechend sauer
wir schätzen dass dieser zug durchaus
bedarf schaffen würde wenn es ihnen gibt
dann denken wir dass gerade jetzt auch
im bereich des ganzen umdenkens pnv dass
der dann auch frequentiert wird
es kann nicht sein dass sich sonntags
predige wir wollen den ländlichen raum
fördern wir wollen was das klima tun und
wenn es dann um eine konkrete
zugverbindung geht die ich sage mal für
den apfel und ei zu haben ist dann heißt
es nie das wollen wir nicht
im zuständigen infrastrukturministerium
in erfurt hält man die frühverbindung
für unrentabel
dafür gebe es keinen bedarf schriftlich
heißt es so ist unausweichlich die zur
verfügung stehenden mitteln möglichst
effizient einzusetzen und an den stellen
einzusparen wo die nachfrage gering und
ein mitteleinsatz daher nicht vertretbar
ist eine entscheidung die die menschen
vor ort wir völligen blödsinn halten
zuge der energiewende halte ich das
natürlich für totalen quatsch am
falschen ende
es gibt genügend gelder die verschwendet
werden dann sollte man doch mal gelder
für die bürger ausgeben
aber beide sind thüringen scheinbar
billiger ist einen zug leer fahren zu
lassen als zahlende fahrgäste
mitzunehmen wird der geisterzug morgens
auch weiterhin wer durch den südharz
rollen das verstehe wer will